do you think a lot of filmmakers
realized that their actions could become
bored of the material that they need to
challenge the actress as much as they do
the audience I think I think I think
that there is a glass ceiling for people
who do not realize it you know what I
mean I think there's I think there's a
level that you can raise to and no
further if you do not have that
understanding and ultimately you look at
the films of someone like Martin
Scorsese or Steven Spielberg and there's
no question now they may be interested
in challenged by different kinds of
actors from each other but you look at
the work that they do and there's no
question that they have that
understanding when it comes to the
performers that they love working with
you know what I mean who has done more
to challenge Tom Cruise then Steven
Spielberg who has you know and Tom
Cruise has grown because of it it's
fascinating to watch them work together
no matter how you feel about either of
their work it's great when they get
together because something they're going
to do something they didn't know they
could do and you know it right away you
don't I mean and that's the core of
regardless of the special effects that
is the core of why the audience is
interested and then they bring in all
the elements that they know how to bring
to a production and all of a sudden it
becomes something it becomes huge you
know and that's why it's cool you know
you know I'm not gonna give any examples
of people who don't know that because
Who am I I don't know anybody good but
but every so often you watch a film and
you're like wow that doesn't quite
doesn't quite grab me you know and it's
usually it usually boils right down to
number one a lack of dramatic thrust
they're not giving the act or omission
the actor is reacting to the story
instead of driving the story forward
which is the most common narrative
that's not drama that's not what an
actor does an actor takes action I think
you know they are the person initiating
the story they have to be doing
something from beginning to end Luke
Skywalker's trying to liberate the
universe and Darth Vader is trying to
enslave it and you just can't have it
both ways are there cues that you can
pick up from your actors that they're
bored I'm sure
besides body language I think by the
time you know to challenge your actors
you know when they're born whether or
not i think by that i think just the act
of getting out there and being like well
how am I going to you'll you'll be
watching for it if you're aware of it
and if you're conscious of it and it
doesn't become an issue and if you're
not concerned with whether or not your
actors are engaged then you're not going
to notice whether they are or not I
think it's just practice you know yes
there are you know um you know but when
people say you know oh this actor that
actor phoned it in it's usually because
they've been typecast they're playing
the same role they played in the last
film and actors factors they don't just
study action what they study is conflict
the hardest way to achieve in action
because the scene begins when two people
want conflicting things and a scene ends
when someone gets what they want it's
over you know what I mean the Death Star
plans are not in the main computer well
let's go ask princess leia I'm not gonna
tell you oh yes you are pretty lady like
and then as soon as they bring in the
droid with the drugs where do you go
from there like well we're gonna torture
her and she's gonna tell us and now we
have to move on to see what Luke is
doing like and the same is true in
sideways I mean any film sideways is
about one guy who really really really
really really wants his friend to have a
successful life and a successful wedding
because he does not any kind of living
vicariously through this guy and the
friend just wants to blow it up just
destroy everything and they both want it
so desperately that it becomes comedy
like but that's that that is the mission
Lynn oh well I'm gonna try and get you
through this dinner without destroying
your life well that didn't work but now
I'm gonna try and get you out of this
house before we both do things well that
didn't work either well now I'm just
gonna try and keep it a secret I'm just
going to know like you know and that's
what sideways is about and and and those
actors are being presented with those
tasks um in a way that keeps them alive
because there's never it's never easy to
achieve it's always difficult and the
great thing about the casting is that
getting into those situations in
demanding things of those performers
that they aren't quite ready for when
they start production and you can see
them working to become the character and
working to become the person not just
who starts the movie but the person who
finishes the movie the person who can
actually learn these lessons and they're
engaged by the material because because
on every level they're experiencing
conflict that study of conflict has but
that mean that's what somebody like
Paula Giamatti does for 40 years or
something that guy's been in scenes
trying to find the hardest way to live
if you don't give him something hard to
do on every level he's going to start
checking out because he he knows his way
through the scene he needs to put
himself in a situation that he's not
completely confident about that he's not
hot a percent sure he can manage and if
you cast an actor in the role but
they're not quite ready for they will be
engaged by the conflict they will go
home panic call everybody they know ask
people to tell them it's going to be
okay once they get the role and then
they're going to start coming to you
with pages of research and they're going
to start comin they'll come with scenes
prepared that they will be off book on
day one like completely there will be no
concern about any of that stuff because
they are building the confidence and
they are building the tool set to make
the movie as great as they can be
because they don't know if it's there
yet they love the challenge they love
the conflict that's all that they do
it's all they know you have to give it
to them in my opinion
you